and I thought maybe I just take a moment
so at the White House and been with me
now three and a half years before I won
before the election is a person a friend
a woman a great great magnificent person
actually named Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and she's very popular
[Applause]
she's done an incredible job but we've
been through a lot together and she's
tough
but she's good you know you also have
tough and bad right she's tough and
she's good she's great and she's gonna
be leaving the service of her country
and she is going to be going I guess you
could say private sector but I hope
she's going to she comes from a great
state Arkansas I was a state I won by a
lot so I like it but we love our concern
she's gonna be going back to Arkansas
with her great family her husband was a
fantastic guy and her family and I don't
know Phil and folks if we can get her to
run for the governor of Oregon so I
think she'll do very well and I I'm
trying to get her to do that
but I just saw her in the room and I
really wanted to call her up she's a
special person a very very fine woman
she has been so great she has such heart
she's strong but with great great heart
and I want to thank you for an
outstanding job and thank you
[Applause]
I'll try not to get emotional because I
know that crying can make us look weak
sometimes right this has been the honor
of a lifetime the opportunity of a
lifetime I couldn't be prouder to have
had the opportunity to serve my country
and particularly to work for this
president he has accomplished so much in
these two and a half years and it's
truly been something I will treasure
forever it's one of the greatest jobs I
could ever have I've loved every minute
even the hard minutes
I have loved it I love the president I
love the team that I've had the
opportunity to work for the president is
surrounded by some of the most
incredible and most talented people you
could ever imagine and it's truly the
most special experience the only one I
can think of that might top it just a
little bit is the fact that I'm a mom I
have three amazing kids and I'm gonna
spend a little more time with them
and in the meantime I'm going to
continue to be one of the most outspoken
and loyal supporters of the President
and his agenda and I know he's gonna
have an incredible six more years and
get a whole lot more done like what
we're here to celebrate today and I
don't want to take away from that so I
certainly want to get back to the
tremendous thing that the people behind
me have done and thank you so much mr.
president's truly an honor
great person
wait thank you Sarah wait she's a
warrior you guys know what warriors are
all right
warriors we're all warriors we have no
choice we have to be warriors in this
world but she is a word thank you sir
very much